hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his essay the present age siren
kierkegaard is going to make a rather
startling claim about what he's calling
the present
age which could be our own he says
that it has nullified the principle
of contradiction and now if you've had
some
you know metaphysics or you've you've
worked through some logic
you might say well wait a second i don't
think that that's actually possible
the principle of contradiction which
is sometimes also called the law of
non-contradiction
seems to be the sort of thing that you
you can't get away from so
what is the the law of non-contradiction
or the principle of contradiction
there's a number of ways of framing it
you can say that contradictory
statements cannot both be true
at the same time or if you have two
contraries
one of them can be true the other has to
be you know
not true right it could be that both are
actually false
but if you've got one you can't have the
other
and so to nullify that would be to say
this could be a book and not a book
or i can be both living and dead at the
same time
and there are ways around that you can
play with words that are ambiguous and
say well you're dead in this sense and
living in this sense you're
you're dead to sin but alive to you know
the possibilities of the world right but
now you're not using the terms
in the same way and so somebody who's
who's
in favor of saying that the law of
contradiction applies everywhere could
say
we can qualify this and say that it's
in the same sense so this can't both
be a book and not be a book at the same
time
in the same sense right or pick whatever
else you want
and so if you put it like that then it
sounds
really strange to say that
anything could could nullify the
principle of contradiction it seems like
once you open the door to that
well anything goes and kierkegaard
doesn't think that
so what's going on here there's
something else
that he has in mind and i think it can
be very helpful if we think about the
content of the law that he is
talking about he's not talking about
pure
theoretical philosophy he's really
talking about
what we call the sphere of the practical
the sphere of action and commitment
choices and it doesn't even have to be
philosophy it can be broader
than that so there's
actions or choices right and we can also
talk about
certain types of comportment
or other things that are that are you
know contradictory or opposed
to each other as being governed by this
as well and we'll look at that in a
moment
but let's start with the thinking about
it in terms of action and choice
so it's very helpful to go back to
the earlier essay because remember the
present age is
is part of a book review in which he
talks about
the present age but he also talks about
the age of
revolution so he tells us that the age
of revolution
is essentially passionate therefore it
has
not nullified the principle of
contradiction
and can become either good or evil
whichever way is chosen the impetus
of passion is such that the trace of an
action
marking its progress or its taking a
wrong direction
must be perceptible so that that's a way
of saying
in an age that actually has passion
people commit themselves for good or for
bad but they commit themselves in one
way or the other
and notice that there is a principle of
contradiction here
choose the good if you choose the good
you don't choose the bad
choose the bad you don't get the good
and as a matter of fact a lot of the
ways in which people go wrong are by
saying
i can have both the good and the bad at
the same time which is really
to choose the bad just to choose it
under a different guise
we can also sometimes say well you have
to choose between
contradictory goods you can't have all
of them
and what decides it for the person
is not simply taking an action it's
being motivated
by passion
an expression of the passion that one
has
that makes one the person that one is
for better or for worse
so he talks a little bit later in that
section
about there being a crucial
either or and he says the presence of
the crucial either or depends on the
individual's
own impassioned desire directed towards
acting decisively
upon the individual's own intrinsic
competence and
therefore a competent man covets in
either or in every situation because he
doesn't want
anything more and so people
do existentially at least
many people want to commit themselves
and
understand where they fit in for better
for worse who they are
for good or for evil so this is an
application
of the principle of contradiction by
a person they choose one side or the
other
in the present age kierkegaard says
this has actually become nullified
so that as he says a person
worn out in reflection
you know is is not going to actually
have that he says
as soon as the individual no longer has
essential enthusiasm in his passion
but is spoiled by letting his
understanding frustrating frustrate him
every time he's going he's
going to act he never in his life
discovers the
disjunction the disjunction is that
dividing thing that says
either this or this not both
and you know if you think about our own
contemporary culture
it's become sort of a truism people say
listen you you got to choose this or you
got to choose this
why why do i have to choose between
those why can't i have both
why does it have to be an either or not
of both ant
there's plenty of things where it could
be a both hand you know if you go to the
buffet
you can have both salad and steak or
soup or whatever you want right that's
the nature of a buffet
but when it comes to certain things in
life
you have to choose or at least so long
as there's this principle of
contradiction in play you have to choose
maybe you can in fact have it all but
kierkegaard is saying you actually can't
so in the the essay the present age when
he's discussing this
he tells us that this becomes an
age of
losing intensity and
gaining extensity this is something
that has been discussed under the the
notion of like the mathematical right
you put together so many people and you
get an individual which by itself sounds
rather paradoxical
and the realm of publicity
the public so he tells us the present
age is essentially a sensible age devoid
of passion
because it's devoid of passion it has
nullified the principle of contradiction
and then he says generally speaking
compared to a passionate age reflective
age gains in x density when it loses in
intensity but this x density may become
the condition for a higher form
and then he goes on and he says this the
existential expression
of nullifying the principle of
contradiction
for a person is to be in contradiction
to oneself
so contradiction doesn't completely go
it goes into one's own being
right to be in contradiction to oneself
so he says the creative omnipotence
implicit in the passion of absolute
disjunction
that leads the individual resolutely to
make up his mind
so this is what the previous age allowed
or what could be possible for the single
individual
in the present age within the realm of
what kierkegaard calls the ethical which
he talks about in this
and within the realm of what he calls
the religious by taking the leap as he
also talks about in this
that is the person who actually can in
fact
have this passion of absolute
disjunction i'm going to do this i'm not
going to do this
i'm choosing this i'm choosing against
this
he says this is transformed by the
extensity of prudence and reflection
what does that mean
well he tells us knowing and being
everything possible to be in
contradiction to oneself that is to be
nothing at all
and so he says again by contrast the
principle of contradiction
strengthens the individual in
faithfulness to himself
so that they you know want to remain
the same thing he would rather be
something small with faithful to himself
than all sorts of things
in contradiction to himself but this
becomes you could say for the person
who's
caught up within the culture of the
present age
who follows what he calls the principle
of sociality
then this disjunction is lost
and something very important is lost in
the process
and this is where we get to what he
calls
annulments of passionate disjunctions
again what are we talking about here so
a disjunction is something that goes
along with the principle of
contradiction
and an annulment is you know the
abolition of it or the erasure of it the
breakdown
of it now interestingly enough both
sides do remain possibilities
for the person but they are not going to
engage authentically existentially in
either side of the disjunction and what
we have here
in chatter formlessness superficiality
philandering
being loquacious is a kind of not quite
middle point or mixture of what's on
either side
but a sign of the breakdown of the
disjunction
so he asks us well what is it to chatter
and he says
it is the annulment of the passionate
disjunction between being silent
and speaking the person who chatters
in a certain way does both and neither
chattering is of less
existential significance than speaking
committing oneself through words
or being silent and in order to
speak you do need sort of a background
of silence to speak against
and silence is broken by speaking
chattering is really
neither of these he says
only the person who can remain
essentially silent can speak
essentially can act essentially
isn't that interesting there's a
connection between talking
and silence and being able to act
essentially
the chattering person is in some respect
not only inauthentic in their discourse
but also in their action says chattering
gets ahead of essential speaking and
giving
utterance to reflection has a weakening
effect on action
by getting ahead of it talkativeness
gains in extensity it talks about
anything and everything and continues
incessantly
so that's one important annulment
he talks about another one as
being formlessness and this is really
interesting
he says what is the what is what is
formlessness it is the annulled
passionate distinction
between form and content you might say
what is that what does that mean there
you form in content
he goes on and he says in contrast to
lunacy or
being crazy and stupidity it may contain
truth
but the truth it contains can never be
essentially true
so you know we have experiences of this
all the time
there there are things that are true but
they're not essentially true they may be
little bits of a narrative where those
bits are actually true
but they construe a narrative that's
actually
in its core false it's being used in
deceptive ways
or misleading ways or superficial ways
ways that just don't mean anything to us
the essentially true is only available
because of this principle of
contradiction
so he says that another key aspect to
this he says
the generality of formlessness and
reflective age devoid of passion
expresses itself in the very opposite
a dominant propensity and inclination to
act
on principle right
and he says that the life of the person
devoid of passion is not a
self-manifesting
and unfolding principle on the contrary
his inner life is a hasty something
continually on the move hunting for
something to do on principle
so this is a very different sense of
principle than
what people had in previous ages and and
i think you can recognize many people
like this in our own time
who are just looking for something that
they can use to justify the stance that
they're taking oftentimes
out of fear or a kind of desire or
hunger
superficiality he brings that up as well
and he says that um what is
superficiality
and its characteristic propensity the
exhibitionist
tendency superficiality
is the annulled passionate distinction
between
hiddenness and revelation
it is a revelation of emptiness which by
and large nevertheless
does not have the deceptive advantage of
jugglery over essential revelation which
has the uniform substance of depth
whereas superficiality gives the
appearance of being anything
and everything so
there's no inner life he says to the
person there's no
hiddenness superficiality is something
that
stands in the way both of authentic
revelation
unfolding uh showing oneself and
hiddenness or remaining within oneself
philandering this is a very interesting
one that
he he brings up what is philandering
screwing around right we would say it is
the null
passionate distinction between
essentially loving
and being essentially debauched so you
know
here kierkegaard is saying listen if
you're going to like
give yourself to hooking up just like
you know i mean it's a bad thing but
just devote yourself to like immorality
and
and you know don't try to sanitize it
don't try to make it
nice and safe realize that you know
you're you're in between here's the two
possibilities
essentially loving you know and we could
talk about it as is
what the uh middle medieval's called
conjugal love where there's a
self-giving
to the other there is a loving in return
that takes place and a commitment or
just like lose yourself and debauchery
one or the other
don't have this well you know we're
we're in an open marriage or well we all
kind of cheat on each other that's what
he's caught to calling philandering
here and he says neither the essential
lover
nor the essential dibachi is guilty of
philandering
here's a really interesting line which
dallies with
possibility philandering is a form of
indulgence that dares to touch evil
and refrains from actualizing the good
and he says by the way there's a
connection between that
and the superficiality and and
formlessness
that involves acting on principle right
because
it uh he says acting on principle is
also philandering
it vitiates moral action to the point of
abstraction
and then he says but in extensivity
flandering is the advantage for you can
flander with
all sorts of things but only one person
can be loved essentially and in the
proper understanding of erotic
love all adding is a subtracting and the
more one adds the more one subtracts
finally he talks about being loquacious
this is going back to the chattering he
says it is the
null passionate distinction between
subjectivity
and objectivity as abstract thought
loquacity is not sufficiently profound
dialectically
as conception and conviction it lacks
full-blooded individuality
but in extensity in how it can be
extended to things
loquacity has the apparent advantage a
thinker can comprehend his branch of
knowledge a person can have a concept of
what's related to a particular subject
but the loquacious person chatters about
anything
and everything so each of these
is a way in which this principle of
contradiction
is nullified in a more specific
mode and these kierkegaard things
are characteristic not only of the
culture of our time
but of many of the people of our time
and that means that they're missing out
on what was on either side of the
disjunction that they would have to
decide
passionately and through their action
you